[音楽]
voodoo
言葉が
音になっていく感覚が
今でも体に残っています
中学生の時どうしても教室に入れなくて学校にも行けない時期がありました
もうそのときのことはあんまり清水に思い出せないけど
大学生になった今でも
この言葉が音になっていく感覚は
ずっと体が覚えています
どういうことなのかを考えて
最近理由が分かりました
私の言葉を
受け取る人がいなかったのです
当時クラスで無視をされ続けていました
誰も
私の言葉に反応しない
届く相手のない言葉は意味を失って
音だけが
そこに残る
言葉が音になっていく
そういう感覚
久しぶりに投稿した日の朝青い顔をして教室の扉を開けと私に同等クラスの女子達が
近づいてきました
大丈夫心配してたんだよなんで休んでたの
明日は学校くるのノート見せてあげる移動教室一緒に行こう
怖いと思った
今まで私のことが見えていなかった彼らが私が不登校になった途端に急に優しくなった
でも気付いてました
誰も私は見てないって
彼らの優しさの先にいるのは私じゃなくて
不登校の人でしたもうずっと前のことで
今更どーってことないけど
時々音も
あれは誰のための優しさだったんだろう
去年の夏南イタリアにボランティアに行った際
これとよく似たことに何度も出会いました
今日はそのお話をしようと思います
イタリアは地図を見ても分かるように海に囲まれています
この地中海を小舟に乗って逃れてくる人たちは過去4年で60万人にもあたります
難民と呼ばれる彼らは戦争や迫害で自分の国から追われるようにして避難してきてい
ます
生きるために
自分の国から逃れてきた人たち
そんな彼らの日 now 生活は平均して26年にも及びます
自分の国も今日も
学ぶ機会も奪われて
それでも毎日
どんな思いで生きてるんだろう
学校っていうひとつの居場所を失った時あんなにつらかった私に
これほど多くの居場所を失った彼らの痛みは計り知れないけど
あの痛みを知ってるからこそ
何か力になりたいと思ったっ
それでシチリア島付近の小さな村へボランティアに向かいました
そこには難民支援を行っている n 子様があって聞けばな民となった人たちにもう
一度学びの場を提供したり
あとは支援に頼りきりにならないよう自立するサポートなども手厚くをこのアピール
トムことですと具体的に私は彼らが運営する学校で先生をさせていただく予定でした
しかし
現地で私を待っていた仕事はこれ
なんだと思います
これペンキ塗り
公園の緑色のフェンスを青色に寝るという仕事ではまた
天気で何か砂場墓所と塗って見てみたいな
なにこれ本当にこれは何だそしてもっと驚いたのが彼らが運営しているっていう学校が
そもそもなかったことを
来る前に聞いていた難民の人たちが暮らしてるっていうキャンプもないというか
そもそも難民の人に待った彼はない
どこを歩いてももうすれ違うのはイタリア地イタリアずねイタリアせ
ええええええ
何度か ngo に反乱を起こしに行ったんですがネジをのボスはペンキ塗りは辛い
気持ちを抱えた難民がきれいなフェイスのある公園を見れば心が p するになる
からって言いました
他にも難民支援を歌って集めた寄付金で建てた
誰も来ない図書館
そこには英語の本しかなくて英語圏じゃない国から避難してきた人はまず読めないし
というかこの図書館の存在自体が全然村に浸透してなくて今では現地のイタリア人の
たまり場のような場所になっています
他にも挙げればきりがないくらいに
なにこれこれは私怨なのかっていう活動でもう
溢れかえっていましたそんな活動にぶち当たるたびにぼせっせと
抗議しに来る私に ngo のボスは決まって
難民は何何だからって始めました
さらにすごく違和感があったひっかかりました
日本に帰ろう変える帰りも走って決めて荷造りを始めた日
彼らに会った
私がペンキを塗りたくって peaceful に仕上がったはずの公演 the 甘く
て山の茂みで
彼らの笑い声が響いてました
アラビア語を話している
陶磁アラビア語は愛するしか知らなかったからとりあえず愛してるアロハな早くて弁護
士て彼らに近づいてきました
でもなんだが近づいた分だけ彼らは離れていきました
完全に警戒されてしまって
やらかしました
しかし根気強くカレーに話しかけて仲良くなろうとトライするうちにだんだんと友達に
なりました
名前はありがとうがざな
シリアのアレッポ出身です
2011年から続くシリア内戦から避難してきたんだそうです
9歳と11歳の子の姉妹は現地のイタリア人が通う学校に一緒に帰っています
全部イタリア語で行われる授業に一生懸命
ついていっています
帰ってきたらイタリア語版のセーラームーンを見てなんとなくでもイタリア語を
つかもうと頑張っていました
ん
こちらは長女のラーニア
何は17才で学校に変えていません
葉には曰くこの場所では16歳以下までしか学校に変えないんだそうです
何はいつも足をこんな風に引きずるようにして歩いていました
どうしたのって聞くたびに答えが違うからきっといいたくないの魂
何をちっちゃい頃から脳のお医者さんになることを夢見てます
学校に通えなくなった今では毎日 youtube で勉強してます
なーにゃと仲良しになって毎日一緒に遊びました
当時私は18歳で何私が近いのもあっていろんな話で盛り上がりました
お父さんお母さん含めて8人家族もこのヘッド一家と3ヶ月ほど一緒に過ごしました
あの研究名のボランティアに行くよりずっと
勝つのある時間に思いました
パパーやっぱり威厳があって誰もパパに逆らったりはしませんでした
とパーよくここはつまらないって言いました
落ちはイタリア政府から支給されています
パパはシリアに残った親戚ドイツトルコ
エヴァのに散って行った友達とか家族とかに密に連絡をとりまくっていました
パパー決まってどこの国れどんな支援が受けられるのか
聞いていました
どこのシーンが一番いいのって聞く私にここの支援は全然ダメって白目を剥きました
私の発展途上のアラビアがのせいで詳しいことは聞けなかったのですが
パパには仕事がありません
シリアでタクシードライバーをしていたというパパですがシリアの土地勘あっても
イタリアのことは分かりません
イタリア語も話せません
聞けば移民のみを受け入れる際にイタリア政府が使い物になるねぇって
した人は北裕福な町にとどまれるんだそうです
ローマとかミラノとか大きい街があるのが来た
例えば専門的な技術とか知識を持っていたり
あとはイタリア語を話せればこのきたにとどまれる
しかしパパには両者ともありませんでした
イタリア政府から使えないってされた人はどんどん南の寂れた街に移されます
私たちがいたのはイタリア最南端のシチリア島のすぐそばでした
この場所で
6年間暮らしています
私がいたときはちょうど難民受け入れやめようキャンペーンのもう真っ最中でアジア
ニュースをつければ決まって波が俺たちの年金を食うとか
イタリアの未来を守るために波う軽量やめようとかもうよく耳にしました
パパが現地のイタリア人と全然合流がなくていつも家に引きこもって
シリア人にばかり電話する理由も
なんとなく
心当たりがありました
この南イタリアに来る前母の友人が暮らすミラノで1週間ほど世話になったときこの
ニュースが流れていました
イタリアも船が小さな小舟に乗って逃れて来ていた難民の人たちは見つけて彼らは救出
しました
してイタリア帰ろうって思ったらイタリア政府はその入国を拒否したんです
彼らに入ってきてほしくないから
ごはん時に流れたこのニュースにこんなの間違ってる
それでも同じ人間があってコーダーっていかれる私に母の友人はそうそうやってまた
イタリアが責められるって言いました
立って間違ってるよねえって大学生になる息子さんに助けを求めたら息子さんは
考えてから
確かにこのニュースは僕も酷いと思うよ
でも
個人的にあんまり入ってきてほしくないかな
ん
朝よく車掌と意味の人たちが揉めるんだよ
彼らお金払わないで乗ってきてるから
払えって言っても俺たちは難民でお金がなくて払えないんだ仕方ないんだどうしようも
ないんだっていうからもうどうすることも出来ないから
次の駅で下すでしょ
そしたら今度
その車掌がみんなから叩かれるんだよ
どうして難民にそんなひどいことをするんだって
そうやって揉めてるところ朝から見たくないんだよね
申し訳なさそうに言いました
こういうよろんが
言葉は分からなくても
なんとなくパパには感じられるんだと思うんです
いづらいんです
この場所が
パパは戦争で自分の仕事も居場所を失ってここで支援金をもらわないと生きていけない
いつ終わるかもわからない何もすることがない
できることがないこの場所で
生きていかなきゃいけない
働かないでお金もらって生きて犬なら最高とかそうだ
浪潮
なんて言葉がネットで飛び交っているけれど
その言葉の先に
この家族がいるなら
それはすごく残酷なことだと思った
最後にこの人の話を
あミラー
私がずっと一緒にいた家族とは別に3年前に構えたりミナム南イタリアに送られてき
ました
20代に見えるよって言ったらすっごい喜ぶ
30代のあみろ
亜美らも同じくシリアのアレッポ出身で家族はドイツ
兄弟はオランダに逃れました
しかしなぜか亜美らのリクエストだけが通らず本人曰くアンラッキー
でこの南イタリアに来たんだそうです
どうしても家族と一緒にいたいからドイツに行かせてほしいというお願いはイタリア
政府にして
片乳の電話がかかってくるの
3年間
ここで持っています
その事実だけでも驚きだけどもっと驚いたのが私がいたときにその電話が掛かってき
たってことです
イタリア政府から現地の ngo を通して亜美らに連絡が来ました
ネジをスタッフは亜美らに今から3日から4日以内に支給しているお家でてってね
それを過ぎたら水も電気も止める市加賀野使っちゃダメ
あと飛行機のチケットも自分で用意してねえって
ゆったんだそうです
あミラー3年間ここにいて
そんな
追われるみたいにして出て行かなきゃいけないなんていって思ったけど
あめらが嬉しそうに笑うから
私も嬉しかっ
阿弥陀出発の前日亜美らが卵やたちの家に来ました
みんなで写真撮ったりハゲしたりいっぱい雨等に大好きな気持ちを伝えました
一通り yy ガチャガチャが済んだところで雨らと話しました
あミラードイツもなんでた頃に行くなって聞いた私に
赤間いっ
あめらは答えました
あのね
私たちはこのイタリアに入国するときに
いろんなドキュメントにサイン書かなきゃいけないんだ
その中に
イタリア語を進んで勉強しますっていうのがあって
私はそれにもサインした
ドイツ月の説明は全部イタリア語でされたよ
でも
私は3年間ここにいたいっ
その私がその説明に
わからないなんて言えないよ
確かにこの場所には平日の昼に1時間ほどイタリア具を習える場所があります
しかしその少しの機械でイタリア語がペラペラ喋れるようになるでしょうか
これはまたイイに行くしかねーなーと思って ngo に反乱を起こしに行こうとする
私に
でもおっ
亜美らは続けました
でも
何か弾方の書かれた紙を見せられて
この番号の飛行機をとれって言っている事は何となく分かった
だからその晩形の紙にメモしてきたんだ
だから
これがあれば
私はきっとドイツに行ける
大丈夫なんだ
第二層に
髪を握りしめるアメロ
亜美らがなんだかいつもよりずっとちっちゃく見えて
弾がなくなっ
持った
この場所で
きっと亜美らの声は
音になっている
どうしてドイツに行きたいのか
3年間
どんな思いでこの場所で生きてきたのか
あめらにドイツ月を言い渡した支援者には
一つ付いてない
亜美らだけじゃないなーにゃもパパの声も
きっとこの場所で音になっている
だから大雪の支援金でペンキフェイスのペンキ塗りしたり誰も来ない空っぽの図書館を
建てたりできるんだ
波は何何だからって言う
ngo のボスの声が
頭をよぎる
この場所で私が目の当たりにしてきます
支援は
あの日のクラスメイトみたい
誰も私を見てなくて
彼らも優しさの先にいるのは私ではなく不登校の人でした
この場所での支援も
ザーにゃんパパ
亜美らじゃない
難民に向けられている
この花は周りの支援と優しさの共通点は一つ
立場でしか
人を見ていないということです
不登校の人は一緒にいてあげれば喜ぶだろう
難民はこういうシーンが必要だろう
少なくとも彼らの活動の根本には優しさだったり
思いやりだったりがあるはずです
しかし
支援者と呼ばれる人ですら
この立場だけで人を見てしまうことがあるんだ
そうやって立場だけで人を見た支援や優しさは
空回りします
誰のための支援課
らにゃんパパ
あミラー
難民としてでなく
一人一人の
個人として向き合えたら
それが難しくてもラジオやニュースで難民と呼ばれるその人たちのその大きな渦の中に
は
一人一人の
個人の人生があるんだって
意識できたら
少なくとも
こんなから周りの支援はなくなる
彼らを難民わーとひとくくりにして語る前に
私とあなたという関係を
意識してみてほしい
くくった途端に
彼らの声は聞こえなくなるからだろう
彼らの言葉を
受け取る姿勢をつくってみてほしい
彼らの声を
言葉を
思いを
ただの音にしてしまわないために
ありがとうございました
[拍手]